ja der chef der kassenärztlichen
der bei bild live ihr sich weniger
sorgen macht von omikron offenbar als um
das zahlen chaos aktuell der
bundesregierung und des
robert-koch-instituts sagt darüber
wollen wir jetzt sprechen mit dem
parlamentarischen geschäftsführer der
union mit thorsten frei herzlich
willkommen mehr frei bei bild live das
zahlen oder aus der bundesregierung in
dieser corona krise wir kennen das seit
vielen monaten ja mittlerweile
eigentlich seit zwei jahren jetzt wird
die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz neue
beschlüsse treffen am freitag auf
welcher basis auf basis von falschen
zahlen kann man das überhaupt
er sie sprechen ein thema an das völlig
zu recht in der kritik steht dass wir im
grunde genommen insbesondere nach den
feiertagen häufig mit nicht validen
zahlen arbeiten das ist insbesondere
dann wenn es um übermittlung probleme
geht im grunde nicht akzeptabel und das
zweite ist dass wir ein monitoring haben
von impfungen an das rk ii aber das ist
natürlich überhaupt nicht zu vergleichen
etwa mit einem nationalen ins register
wie wir es aus österreich kennen das im
grunde genommen einen permanenten
abgleich von melde und ins register
ermöglicht und deswegen ist es etwas
wovon ich glaube dass wir es dringend
benötigen und die bundesregierung
deshalb auch schnellstmöglich die
arbeiten so etwas umzusetzen aufnehmen
sollte erwarten sie von der mpk am
freitag dass dieses thema angegangen
wird
ja ich halte das für eine wichtige
voraussetzung auch für die frage
inwieweit man eine impfpflicht in
deutschland umsetzen kann der
bundeskanzler hat ja bereits im letzten
jahr gesagt dass er so etwas befürwortet
er hat aber weder einen vorschlag
vorgelegt noch ist er bereit essentielle
fragen wieso etwas umgesetzt werden
könnte zu beantworten und insofern
erwarte ich mir von der bundesregierung
natürlich schon dass sie sagt was sie
will weil sie als lösungsweg für richtig
hält und dann auch einen gangbaren weg
beschreibt die als
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am freitag
die wird sich mit der frage beschäftigen
müssen inwieweit es gelingt sowohl auf
die individuellen unterschiede
einzugehen als auch transparente und
nachvollziehbare
lösungen für ganz deutschland anzubieten
das halte ich für zwingend notwendig
auch um die akzeptanz in der bevölkerung
einigermaßen aufrecht zu erhalten also
sie erwarten von olaf scholz vom
bundeskanzler dass er jetzt sagt wir die
impfpflicht umsetzen will das nehmen wir
mit noch einmal ganz kurz zu den zahlen
sie erwarten auch dass die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
bundesregierung am freitag klar benennt
wie man das zahlen chaos aufheben möchte
und bis wann auch bis wann ja natürlich
auch das erwarte ich und darüber hinaus
noch einen dritten punkt es geht bei der
hochinfektiösen
mikrowellen letztlich auch darum wie man
es schaffen kann insbesondere die
kritische infrastruktur aufrecht zu
erhalten und dabei ist es glaube ich
ganz entscheidend nicht nur darauf zu
schauen wie man zurecht kommen könnte
wenn 30 prozent der beschäftigten
ausfallen würde sondern auch wie die
einzelnen sektoren
untereinander miteinander kommunizieren
und wie auf dieser grundlage das
öffentliche leben aufrechterhalten
werden nochmals kurzem herr frei bis
wann müssen jetzt valide zahlen
vorliegen was muss die erwartungen an
die bundesregierung sein bis wann ist
das zahlen desaster geklärt das muss so
schnell wie möglich passieren wir kennen
das aus der vergangenheit dass es nach
den feiertagen immer einige tage in
verzug gibt aber gerade bin ich das ins
register angesprochen hat dann ist es
etwas was man sofort auf den weg bringen
muss und zwar in einer bürokratie abend
lösung damit sie uns tatsächlich bei der
aktuellen problemen hilft eine ganz
andere frage bleiben sie dabei das ist
nicht sinnvoll ist hans-georg massen aus
der cdu auszuschließen carina das jetzt
auch wieder gefordert
ich halte es ehrlich gesagt nicht für
sinnvoll solche diskussionen zu führen
weil sie im grunde genommen hans-georg
maßen nur aufwerten in deutschland ist
es extrem schwer jemanden aus einer
partei auszuschließen diese erfahrungen
haben alle demokratischen parteien in
deutschland bereits gemacht und zurecht
ist es so dass man nicht mit allem
einverstanden sei muss was mitglieder
der eigenen partei sagten auch als buße
minder meinungen sind da erlaubt und
deswegen rate ich einfach auch dazu
klare kante zu zeigen klar zu machen
dass das was hans georg maßen sagt
nichts mit der cdu als partei zu tun hat
aber wir werden auch abstruse meinungen
in unserer partei zu lassen müssen also
das theater aber niemand aus dass
diskutieren und nicht ausschließen ist
das motto
ich würde sagen weder das eine noch das
andere
diskutieren hoffentlich schon
na ja man darf das auch nicht
überbewerten
hans-georg maßen hat keine funktion die
nach rap der ziele ja ja wie er
polarisiert partei stark und karin prien
hat sich dazu geäußert die diskussion
kriegen sie ja nicht mal wieder
eingefangen wie es ja schon da
ja ich glaube nur eine diskussion die
man nicht so einem erfolgreichen ende
führen kann die lohnt es auch nicht zu
führen der auffassung bin ich und den
ratschlag kann ich nur meinen
parteifreunden und parteifreunden
übermitteln wir an karin prien danke für
das gespräch an den parlamentarischen
geschäftsführer der unions-fraktion an
thorsten frei danke danke schön sehr
gerne